So we've reached the end of unit four. I hope you
feel like you understand at a high level what's going on in
a web browser, what's going on when you request a page
over the internet. There's certainly lots of details, we're not going to cover
them all in this class. But I think you should have
a pretty clear picture of everything that's going on. There's nothing that's
magic here, everything can be understood.
Everything's done by sending messages across
the internet and getting responses back and the responses are just text
that are processed either by your web browser or now by
your very own web crawler that you've written, and now you've got
a search engine that can respond to queries. So, congratulations for
making it to the end of Unit Four. There'll be a homework
to do now, and in Unit Five we're going to look at
the problem of how to actually make our search engine scale. The
search engine that we've built in unit four works, it gives us
responses to queries, it doesn't do that in a very fast or
smart way. That's what we're going to improve in unit five. We're
going to make it so that we can respond to queries much faster
than we can with the code that we've written so far.
And then in unit six we're going to look at the very interesting
question of how do you find the best response for a
given query. We don't usually want to get all the pages that contain
the search word we're looking for. What we want to do is get
the best page. And that's what we'll look at in unit six.